here's gomber's 16th start
and now it's a 76-23 better than three
to one ratio strikeout to walk
and first pitch ground ball to second
that'll work and jp crawford
is gone on a four to three two and two
from gobber
and he got him on a hard slider down and
in
good looking pitch yeah way to come back
after
being behind the count 2-0 how about the
movement
on that pitch and this is in the air to
top it deep left but he's got room
[Applause]
he makes the catch so welcome back
austin gobber gina middleton is up on
the mound
and in his career this marks his 120
big league appearance his first career
start
this is going to be a problem for
seattle
and it's a base hit for rymel
so with one out rymel 90 feet away for
charlie blackman coming up
this is a base hit charlie waits long to
drive in the rocky's first run stay hot
chuck
nasty he's now eight for 17
since the all-star break the fly fishing
must have treated him well yeah he had
the good days off
so here's story here's a base hit the
other way
that'll work so we'll stop at second and
here's ryan mcmahon
with two on and one out and matt loops
this toronto
drop charlie had to wait he'll get a
stop sign from stu
cole and then for a moment stu tried to
wave him again when
mitch haniger overran it by a step so
the bases are jammed for
cj crone and he draws
a four-pitch walk to force in a run it's
two to nothing
and that'll bring up dom nunez nunez
drives it high and deep right center
field way back at the very
top of the wall two runs and scored cj
crow coming home
he'll score three run double dumb
yes yeah last night the rock he's two
for nine with runners in scoring
position
momentarily i thought we were gonna have
a grand slam on our hands
about three quarters of the way up that
wall in right field
stay connected dom with that swing
leading things off for the mariners here
in the top half of the second will be
third baseman kyle seeger
seeger jumping on the first pitch a deep
drive
out to deep center field and it's gone
over the wall the big wall no less for a
home run
mariners start their comeback right away
lead off home run kyle seeger his 18th
about 439 feet on that home run
exit velo 105. five to one the rockies
leading
austin gomber embarking on the fourth
inning swung on and missed austin gomber
strikes out mitch hanigar for the second
time
his third punch-out overall and uh first
time got him with the chain jump
but his change up sometimes he'll fade
away sometimes it'll cut
this is right into the shift and a
strong inning from austin gomber
strikeout a fly out and a ground down
second and third one out and that'll
bring up rhino topia
this ball in the air deep center field
this will get hillyard home easily
will make the catch and nunez tagging up
he's got a hustle
but make it six to one good at back from
tapia
and make it 40 rbis for tapia first
baseman luis thorens will lead off the
top half of the fifth then
turns with a blast out to left
there goes another luis terrence his
home run tear
cannot be stopped number 11 on the
campaign
and his ninth sense coming back to the
ball club
makes it the low of 101 387 feet on a
line
mitch hadiger he's over two gombers
struck him out on a changeup in the
fourth
blast deep to left mitch hanigaard goes
on top of the walkway tarp third home
run today
for the mariners they knew it exit velo
99 miles an hour 415 feet that was shot
from a cannon number 23
for hanaker new rockies reliever michael
gibbons
28 appearances on there opponents
hitting 237 and the 26 and two thirds 31
strikeouts
here's seeger swinging and sending a
ball to hilliard out in center field
easy play for sam and he makes the catch
2-2 and a strikeout givens fans
tourettes two outs in the seventh
night with 95 right at the knees
turns was late with the swing
hard shot right at story he's gonna run
to the bag and win the race with tom
murphy good fielding play by
trevor now we're in the bottom of the
seventh and eric swanson will take over
for darren mccakin swaying in a miss
two gun first strikeout for eric good
fastball
rogers to right this is deep
it is over the head and rogers should
easily have a triple
haneker having trouble with it in the
corner
and a two out three bagger for
number seven brendan rodgers and
it's a high fly ball to left center
field
dylan boy's calling for it he's got it
and the rockies will leave rogers
at third rocky's leading the mariners
six
to three carlos estebans will handle the
top of the eighth inning
and that is strike three on crawford at
98.
big punch out from esteban to god in the
eighth
this is on the ground to third max got
it
got that strong r good inning for carlos
estevez johann ramirez is up on the
mound
just his seventh appearance swinging a
miss
going after that slider for route number
one after ramirez when he can work ahead
of you
and go to that slider especially to the
right-handed hitters it's so difficult
to lay off of it's sharp he throws it
hard
three call mcmahon not happy about it
ben may the whole plate umpire disagrees
with him
good fastball 95 just off the outside
corner
right to jp crawford we go
to the ninth inning daniel bart will be
asked to get the last three outs
and the rockies make another change
defensively
right field pretty well head charlie
will make
difference in routes from what happened
earlier off the bat of brennan rogers
and mitch hanigar the route by charlie
much cleaner much
more direct 2-2 to seeger look to the
center field
hilliard plenty roof
two outs three and two from bard
he's got a strike three ball game over
rockies win it 6-3 earn a split with
seattle